[In the hall of the mountain king plays]
[laughs]
This sure is a long way to go for instant death...
HI EVERYBODY!
O-ookay.
Chicken gotta fly!
Chicken gotta go "bye-bye"!
OH!
I didn't think I was getting to death quite fast enough,...
... so I did turbo booster, so I'd be able to go farther...
...fly higher...
...get deader!
HIT IT!
AUWGH!
Smash into it with your facehole...
...right there!
Right there!
Powers of the Donk!
Protect me from death!
I don't think that worked.
Come on! I need EVEN MORE speed!
You seem to have... you got... you went a little...
Okay, whatever!
Well done!
Hit your target! HIT YOUR TA--
Favourite pose EVER of anything!
AW YEAH!
AUGH.
Hit the roof!
[PAIN NOISES]
WEEE!
Oh-oh!
I seem to have lost my vehicle!
Oookay I found another one!
I think it'll end well.
AUGH!
COME ON, BABY!
Show me the noise!
There it is.
What is it actually take to win this game?
Auuugh.
AAA - STOP IT!
What are you doing?
Why?
Because I can.
WEEEE!
MWECH.
How you feeling there, buddy?
You feeling good?
I feel good.
Hiiii!
Byeeee!
Wh-what the...?
Ow. YOU GET OUTTA HERE!
Haven't I been through enough?
NOOO!
Ahh, this should be fun!
Where did I go?
Over there and over there...
...and over there and over there.
FRIMSHLAMFLIMFLAM...
...come on bring on the BAM!
That ain't normal!
Bring on the BAM!
There's the bam.
NoOoOoo!
NOoOoOO!
You're such an ass!
I got turbo pads now...
...you're gonna go over that ramp...
...you little douche!
Don't even try to stop!
That's right!
What a relaxing day for death!
Nice dooooonk.
Why did you get into it donk first?
Auwgh.
Auuuwgh.
Go, my little friend!
Walk right into it!
What the hell happened?
AAAAAAH!
[laughs]-you dick!
Maybe this one will get me in there better...
NOPE!
AAAAH-HAH!
Oww-that bus was coming right for me!
Come on, get in there!
I don't even think my donk can protect me.
OKAYNO!
Come on! I believe in you, you beautiful bird!
Maybe not.
All right! That's all for now!
I had a lot of fun making this one, so...
...if you enjoyed this video...
...and you still wanna...
...see more Turbo Dismount in the future...
...leave a like down below...
...and lemme know in the comments.
Thanks again everybody for watching!
...and I will see you...
...in the next video!
Bye-bye!
[outro music]